hi guys itself right again and this is
the first episode of my new let's play
park and first and foremost I got many
requests for different kinds of themes
got space themed requests Western
requests but I got most requests were
actually requesting medieval themed
theme parks but the problem with that is
that it's kind of in my comfort zone so
I don't want to work with that so I came
up with a plan well I didn't really come
up with a plan I come up with the random
ID I have no idea if this is going to
work or not to make a medieval steampunk
crazy rain forest kind of theme park I
don't I've no idea what this is going to
be like and I haven't I haven't seen
anything like that before so I'm just
going to try this and without any
planning ahead I'm just going to build
random [ __ ] because I know that I know
for a fact it's going to be very hard to
make something that's better than Verona
Valley so I'm just going to experiment
with [ __ ] and see what will come out of
it
so today the first episode I'm going to
make the entrance so I'm just going to
mess around with that
here hero
huhuhuh I wanna be a hero hero
Oh
all right so they'll be the entrance
building and yes I took way too long to
built this I mean it's not even that
much yet I took an entire episode for
this for just this well that's that's
what I get I suppose for doing some
experiments because I have no I had no
idea beforehand what's at I should use
what kind of look I should go for but it
looks kind of decent I mean I can see
some of the steampunk elements in it and
some of the medieval ones and it's not
really 100% amazing though I still feel
like it lacks something mom not sure
what but I might I might come back on
this later on so yeah that's it for this
episode and next episode I'm going to do
some path work and start doing the
general layout of the park so till then